so today we want to talk about the most
accurate way to assess your blood sugars
okay
so we'll talk about a1c
checking your blood glucose when you're
fasting
and checking your blood glucose when
you're post meal i'm not going to
actually mention the glucose tolerance
test where you're going to consume
actual glucose and then measure your
blood sugars simply because you're never
going to consume just pure glucose in
your diet okay so that's not going to
really give you an accurate assessment
of what's going on so let's start with
a1c okay a1c is not as accurate as blood
glucose simply because it's not
measuring your blood glucose levels
directly it's giving you a rough
estimate of your blood sugars over three
months what it's really measuring is the
percent of hemoglobin that is bound to
glucose now hemoglobin is the
protein that carries oxygen in your
blood so a1c is the percentage of how
much hemoglobin that's connected to that
sugar okay in your blood now there's
other similar measurements you have a1b
a1 a1 a1a2 that's not binding to glucose
but the a1c is so this is what they use
to assess that now let's talk about
anemia there's a couple different types
one is where you have low iron
if you have the type of anemia that is
low iron you're going to have an
abnormally high a1c giving you a false
reading with your blood sugars so it's
not going to really be as accurate to
actually indicate high blood sugar
issues
now there's another type of anemia
called hemolytic where you're actually
having destruction of the red blood
cells
in which case you're going to have a
very low a1c
you can also have an infection which can
throw this off you can also have a liver
disease or a kidney disease or even
being pregnant and it can throw off this
number right here so we want to just use
this as a guideline it's not a bad test
but realize it's not 100
all right now let's just bring up the
point what is normal blood sugar well it
should be in the 80s
roughly between 70 and 90
milligrams per
deciliter but if you are a diabetic
you're
most likely not going to achieve this
right here
at least initially until you're working
on it for many many months even
sometimes years
because if you're a diabetic
especially you've been a diabetic for a
long time you have
insulin resistance and many times you've
lost up to 50 of your beta cells those
are the cells that actually make insulin
so we're really dealing with a
dysfunctional pancreas and it's going to
be really hard to bring this down simply
because you don't have all the cells
that make insulin and this is going to
leave you with a slightly elevated blood
glucose level okay
now if you really work on this and you
do intermittent fasting over a period of
time i believe you can bring it down
pretty close to a normal level okay
here's one of the challenges that i see
with diabetics they're going to their
doctor and the doctor is assessing them
and they're
they might be improving but they can't
seem to get the blood sugar down without
a lot of medication okay not to mention
the recommendations that they're giving
the person is usually higher
carbohydrate
low fat you know
type foods
so they're never going to be able to get
them
even close to normal especially if their
carbohydrates in their diet are just too
high so that's one thing but usually
diabetics have a lot of complications
they have high blood pressure they have
eye problems they have nerve problems
they have heart problems they have
cholesterol problems
and they have a fatty liver so they're
on a lot of different medications
and the real problem is the
side effect from those medications are
sometimes worse
than the side effects from the high
sugar okay
now if you are a diabetic and you do the
keto plan and you're doing intermittent
fasting and you're doing great but you
can't seem to get this down
to where it needs to be and it's it's
higher just realize you can do certain
things to neutralize and minimize the
complications
of that high sugar okay
and you can do it with high nutrient
dense foods okay that's why it's so
important when you do a healthy keto
plan to make sure those foods are high
quality
having enough vitamin a
vitamin c from food
b1
vitamin e vital okay those are all
antioxidants that are really really
important especially if that on b1 if
you have enough b1 and get it from
nutritional yeast or a natural source
even if you have high sugar
the complications will be very minimal
okay
so that's what you want to do if your
diabetic kind of get diverted there a
little bit
okay so let's go to the next test
fasting blood glucose level this is not
a bad test it'll give you some data and
of course normal would be like 80 okay
really roughly between 70 and 90. but
when it gets above 110
milligrams per deciliter that's when you
start to have problems okay start do you
have damage to the cells of the pancreas
they're called beta cells
it's at 110.
when you start getting above 140
you start to have more problems with the
other tissues like the heart especially
the inside of your arteries okay you'll
start getting inflammatory conditions
the kidney
the nerves the fingertips and the bottom
of the feet
and the brain okay so so if you get your
test back and it's above 140 then we
know what's happening with this okay but
again if you're a diabetic okay and
you're on keto and you're doing really
good
it might be really hard to even get it
down here at least initially
but that's okay if you keep eating
really healthily you'll be protective
now the absolute best and most accurate
way to assess your blood sugars is post
meal
okay
one to two hours this gives you the
dynamics of how your pancreas
releases insulin to push those blood
sugars down
normal after one to two hours should be
120 or less
and then eventually at two hours it
should be below 100 okay so anything
above that would be a problem
so this right here is rarely
talked about it's it's really assessed
now if you have a blood glucose meter i
would highly recommend focusing on this
assessment right here as your method
of knowing your blood sugars are in
check all right thanks for watching
so if you've personally benefited from
the information that i put on my videos
i would love to actually see your
success story too i put a link down
below so you can upload your before and
after pictures with your story